[Musique]
c'est la seule course au mondial et à la
can saison soir
[Musique]
il
c'est l'aviron de la viande hachée et
tout comme ça pour préparer le palier la
marocain et la chorba algeria et où je
suis venue acheter ça voilà alors ça
c'est pour faire de la chorba c'est du
blé tendre concassées c'est pour faire
de la chambre ça s'appelle du fric c'est
pas de l'oseille
[Musique]
là les cats a fait samedi ça fait 20 ans
avec celle là ça fera 25
il ya aussi des restrictions toujours la
limite de 10 km nous ça nous impacte ça
nous a pris quand même beaucoup et nous
les clients et viennent d'assez loin il
ya des clients qui viennent de cergy
parfois de versailles et vu que les et
des contrôles et à l'extérieur du
magasin
c'était difficile pour eux de venir et
de se prendre une amende pour acheter
quelques articles pour le ramadan
[Musique]
on était dans un climat anxiogène les
gens ne voulaient pas sortir de chez eux
de peur justement d'attraper le
coronavirus canton ils ont fait appel à
nous nous on était là sur le marché dans
les listes depuis deux ans et ça a été
un tremplin c'est vrai pour nous on a eu
beaucoup plus de commandes
ici on a les catégories donc boucherie
volaille crémerie poissons traiteur on a
une large gamme de produits en frais
secs et surgelés
[Musique]
bonjour madame nadia mais oui c'est bien
moi
elle associe la louche je trouve que
c'est très bien le livreur ils arrivent
ils déposent les courses il sonne il n'y
a pas de contacts et rien de tout donc
ça c'est très important aussi parce que
finalement supermarché on trouve une
queue que c'est vraiment pas possible à
19 heures ça ça fait quoi
[Musique]